Less than a billion years ago,
Life crossed a threshold.
Single cells started to band together,
eventually evolving into the riot of shapes
and functions of multicellular life today.
It’s been thought that the evolution
of multicellularity must have been
a major genetic leap but new research
suggests that it wasn’t such a
difficult transition after all.
Scientists looked at an organism
that seems closest to making this leap.
Choanoflagellates while single-celled,
resemble the specialized cells that line
the channels of sponges, which are considered
by many to be the most primitive living animal.
A lab found 350 gene families in Choanoflagellates
once thought to be exclusive to multicellular animals.
The findings suggest that this single-celled
organism is already equipped for multicellular life.
A single cell’s life is simple but limited.
Like hermits, microbes need only be concerned
with feeding themselves.
In contrast, cells in a multicellular organism,
give up their independence;
they take on specialized functions;
they sacrifice their progeny to the greater
good.
Take volverine algae, which comes in
a spectrum of cellularity.
A lab compared the biology and genetics
of this diverse set of algae and learned
that as cells banded together, existing genes
took on new functions.
Chlamydomonas is a single-celled alga
that uses its centrioles for both swimming
and reproduction, so can’t do both
at the same time.
Its multicellular relative, Volvox, however,
can do both at once because its cells
have specialized -with some using the centriole
for swimming and others using it for reproduction.
Yeast is a fungus consisting of a single cell.
One lab conducted a series of test tube experiments
with yeast cultures to better understand
how cells evolved increasing complexity.
The biggest cells, which were the ones
that settled to the bottom of the flask,
were allowed to survive and reproduce.
Within 2 months, daughter cells stuck
to their mothers and formed multicellular
structures dubbed snowflakes because of their shape.
Over time they got bigger and more and more complex.
In this sped up simulation of evolution,
the yeast specialized cells.
In large snowflakes, certain cells cell undergo
a type of suicide releasing the cells at the tip
to start a new snow flake.
The dying cell sacrifices its life so that the group
can reproduce--a hallmark of multicellularity.
The team conducted the same experiment
with Chlamydomonas and again,
a kind of multicellularity was quick to appear.
Scientists are still debating what drove
simple cells to become more and more complex,
but with these genetic comparisons
and clever experiments, what was once thought
as a major leap can now be seen
as a series of small genetic steps
that lead to the wondrous diversity
of multicellular life today.